also breaking tonight russia is now
blocking access to facebook amid the
kremlin censorship and their propaganda
campaign russian lawmakers are even
moving ahead on pursuing jail time for
those who publish so-called fake news
reports about the russian army and
senator lindsey graham well he's been
attacked ever since he made some remarks
on this program last night and saying
that someone needs to take putin out
here with reaction from the media mob
and from team biden take a look
as long as we're talking about reckless
behavior peter i want to ask you about a
tweet from south carolina senator
lindsey graham who writes is there a
brutus in russia in terms of reckless
behavior this is a u.s senator putting
out a public statement like that who was
the chief prosecutor
in europe for the u.s air force years
ago
well certainly a provocative statement
well first of all who cares what lindsay
says right no
united states yeah but you think any
russian general is going to be listening
to what lindsey graham is saying you
don't think that putin could use that as
propaganda the united states
over there senator lindsey graham said
last night that someone ought to
assassinate the president who does the
white house have any take on that
statement is it helpful at this point
that is not the position of the united
states government and certainly not a
statement you'd hear from come from the
mouth of anybody working in this
administration
all right joining me now south carolina
senator lindsey graham to respond to
this criticism senator you just heard
our reporting of what's happened in the
last 24 hours since you made that
statement
towns annihilated neighborhoods leveled
uh
entire areas wiped off the map and we've
heard about targeting civilians that
would be innocent men women and children
uh so in the context of what
we heard reported right here on this
program tonight that i think would
justify the idea that if you have a
conscience and a soul and you're around
vladimir putin uh i don't care by
whatever means necessary stand up and
stop this because innocent people are
dying including kids
well thank you for having me i spoke to
the ukrainian ambassador
earlier today
your voice is breaking through
after i listen to your program every
night putin needs a longer table
uh here's what i would say i've been a
military prosecutor defense attorney
judge for
30 something years i'm going to
introduce a resolution next week i'll
give it to you on your show declaring
that putin is a war criminal
it's clear to me
the world would be better off if the
russian people took putin out tonight
the war in ukraine would end and russia
would have freedom they don't enjoy
today a steel curtain has descended upon
the russian people
what does that tell me that putin is
afraid of his own people martial law has
been virtually declared by putin i think
the russian people are not buying what
putin is selling when it comes to the
ukraine and if the ukrainian people
continue to fight as brave as they are i
think eventually the dam will break in
russia but i want to say this crystal
clear without apology without
equivocation the world would be better
off if putin were gone tonight and the
best way to end this war is not american
boots on the ground but for the russian
people to rise up reclaim the honor of
their country and take this guy out
putin by any means necessary and if you
don't understand that you don't
understand this war and you don't
understand the world in which we live i
don't know what part of targeting
civilians annihilating towns
leveling neighborhoods and wiping entire
cities and buildings off the off the map
people wouldn't understand
i know that we have an executive order
if the first executive order was under
president ford the current one i think
it was under reagan 1233 that prohibits
the united states from engaging in
assassination um with that said uh there
are people around that have access to
putin maybe his generals maybe his
advisers
you're right that's probably not a table
long enough to really protect them but i
got to imagine that the russian people
if they knew
what was truly happening here and i bet
you many of them do
they don't support this
uh from from the people some russians
have already spoken out against it high
profile athletes etc um you know why is
that even controversial considering if
you cut the head off of snake you kill
the whole snake it would probably end
the war wouldn't you think and if
there's somebody that follows putin you
worry well he may be worse but in the
back of that person's mind he's going to
be thinking about what just happened to
putin wouldn't he
well in the 30s when people were calling
for getting rid of hitler and hoping the
german people would stop him
they were considered provocative
looking back in time don't you think the
world had been a better place if the
german people had stopped hitler by any
means necessary don't you think the
world have been a better place we've
stopped the balkans war before the
genocide i'm here to tell you without
equivocation without apology i believe
the world would be a better place if the
russian people took putin out and to the
russian people
your future
is in your hands it's easy to talk about
on television i know it's hard to do
martial law a curtain has descended upon
you and your freedom but please
we need a russian spring if the russian
people rose up and took this man down
the war in ukraine would stop the
russian people would regain its honor
and if we don't do this sooner rather
than later thousands are gonna die
tens of thousands lindsay maybe hundreds
um is anyone paying attention to the hit
squads that putin has sent in to ukraine
to assassinate president zielinski who
frankly has shown amazing courage under
fire in my opinion i don't know him that
well but him staying and fighting and
inspiring his people uh is kind of
refreshing because a lot of leaders by
this point would have gotten on a
private jet with millions of dollars of
currency and gold and and left the
country and he's staying with his people
that's amazing i'm going to speak with
him tomorrow with all members of the
senate he's he's an inspiration and i
just want to say this you're on the
right side of history i'm on the right
side of history
calling for putin to be taken down now
to avoid
more innocent lives being lost is the
right thing to do asking the russian
people for a russian spring is the right
thing to do helping the ukrainian people
with weapons is the right thing to do
when it comes to the biden
administration they're weak and they're
slow we should have done this months ago
when it comes to oil and gas sector but
i'm gonna i'm gonna just let you know if
we don't get this right if putin
prevails he survives yet again after
after one war crime after another on
television every night china is gonna
take taiwan and the iranians are gonna
break out for a bomb how this end
matters and let it end now let it in
with the russian people taking this thug
and war criminal down
i'll add one last thing and stop
importing russian oil that means the us
and that means our allies in western
europe and by the way don't even
contemplate taking in or importing
iranian oil that would be about well
maybe the equivalent or even dumber
senator lindsey graham thank you for
being with us i agree with you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else